mediascape hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zu einer chilligen folge
pixel kleider
ich spiele eine runde mit mir selbst
weil ich die schnell gestartet habe als
noch keiner drin war und ich kann heute
das muss ich leider schon sagen nicht so
super viel schneiden wenn ich überhaupt
schneiden kann weil ich gleich nach köln
fahren ich muss noch mit franz mit - tut
lucky gestern aufnehmen für seinen kanal
das kommt hier am samstag also morgen
und ja wenn ich deshalb überhaupt was
hochladen will dann musste ich halt
vermutlich in one take a hochladen
hier können wir sowieso gern meine
kommentare schreiben fällt euch das auf
das sich in letzter zeit mehr bearbeitet
habe dass mehr geschnitten habe mir mühe
gegeben habe generell weil ich habe mir
echt schon ein paar gedanken gemacht so
was was kannst du machen qualität
qualitativ was kannst du verbessern und
mich wird es echt interessieren ob das
ob das ankommt bei euch bei ein paar mal
habe ich schon den kommentaren gelesen
manchmal auch beschrieben alle videos
sind schlechter geworden so eine person
darf user haben wir jetzt die schneider
voll vielen normalerweise und was ist
denn da so viel schlechter geworden aber
ja keine ahnung jedem die seiner
auffassung vielleicht haben den der
personen die videos davor so gut
gefallen ich nicht so viel gemacht habe
dass sie jetzt einfach die bearbeiteten
schlechter 100 ich weiß es nicht genau
aber ich würde hoffen oder denken dass
der allgemeinheit von euch das doch
aufgefallen ist weil ich stecke schon
relativ viel mehr zeit rein in die
videos und ich ging auf einige mühe
nicht so
jeden tag das gleiche hochzuladen immer
zeiten jeden tag etwas jeden tag
survival games und das ist das
schlimmste finde ich bei dem ganze spiel
jeden tag bei prosieben tags 3d games
und jetzt zur zeit habe ich so eine
phase wo ich einfach das ist das aller
aller stimmt sogar dem war schon das
schlimmste aber dass jetzt alle
allerschlimmste dieser dritte ring da
dieser kleine ringe die zwei wochen
durch liegen mussten schon schlimm genug
aber dieser hier habe ich ein hass auf
das ding das ist so schlimm ich bleibe
da immer dran hängen
denon schlimmeren hass auf den opengl
fehler der mich immer heimsucht wenn ich
das hier spiele kauft das land macht des
landes lang noch bislang noch perfekt
gehe weil wenn ich dieses ding schaffte
dann ist es meistens irgendwie so und
nicht irgendwie ligety sondern ich
gleite dann so laut ich leite dann so
irgendwie neu ich gleite sie dann
irgendwie noch drüber hier ist gerade
auf gesehen hat so zack zack & schott
der erwischen wir doch leute minecraft
gecrasht was soll man da noch machen
kann mir das jugend jemand sagen ich
überlege gerade ob jetzt besser das oder
gar nichts weil wahrscheinlich würde ich
sonst gar nichts hochladen können
aber das so komisch ich hab immer bei
diesem spielmodus habe ich irgendwie
immer den opengl fehler nur bei dem
spielmodus ist es so schrecklich dann
kommt bei dem spielmodus bin ich
irgendwie pflege führung gerade das
macht spaß ich es läuft gerade und dann
kommt auch dieser open gl fehler und
schließt mein spiel
und jetzt kann ich das alternativ nichts
vor produzieren wenn ihr seht dann ab
vielleicht verständnis dafür
weil ich wollte euch nicht wieder ohne
video lassen und auch wirklich gerne mal
eure meinung wissen
zu der qualitätsverbesserung geschichte